i have eyes on loki i'm not loki
hollywood idolizes the actors who play
our favorite characters but
who are the real behind the scenes
superheroes stunt doubles are a huge
reason why movies have such epic action
scenes but they pay the price for having
to wear the most uncomfortable costumes
chris pratt's stuntman he was forced
into an unbreathable mask that he
couldn't even see through
ready to find out more i'm trying to say
that something is coming
when you hear 2 am you probably think of
something like night or sleep
but for monique ganderton it was the
start of her day she doubled for both
nebula and guardians of the galaxy and
mystique and x-men the last stand
if her 2 am call time wasn't bad enough
she would spend
hours in the makeup chair before even
getting to work
you're weak i'm you
mystique required over six hours of
makeup and prosthetics total
she called working with prosthetics
challenging because you're fighting and
sweating in it
it's constantly needing to be touched up
i had to sit through
seven to eight hours of makeup every
every day meet chris ramrell the guy who
did
all of chris pratt's stunts as star-lord
in avengers infinity war
and end game it's gonna look awesome uh
when chris does it
sure star-lord's mask looks cool but if
you found out how it
actually was for chris romrell to wear
it you'll probably think differently
while wearing the mask ramrell says he
literally couldn't breathe or
see while he was doing his stunts in an
interview he said
once you start moving in it and doing
action stuff you lose
all the oxygen in there real quick chris
pratt's mask was equipped with a fan
but ramrell's was so badly made he broke
it three times during filming
luckily someone finally noticed the
hashtag struggle
and swapped the mask for vfx so i can
hit that and
when i'm doing giant stunt sequences
that's the one thing i forget to do
we all love seeing captain america using
his superhuman powers in a fight
but it's not always chris evans who's
under that suit
it's his double daniel hargrave along
with a harness that can be pretty
painful
the harness is needed to bring captain
america's powers to life but it once
caused daniel to be dragged
face first 20 yards by the harnesses
string he suffered a bad hamstring
injury and a bruised ego after he says
he passed
all these superheroes while being
dragged ouch
i saw a few stuntmen take a few nasties
tumbles you know like really really
hitting the ground hard
catwoman riding the bat cycle was
actually iconic
no doubt about it and we have jolene van
view to thank for all that footage
she slipped into a getup identical to
anne hathaways for the scenes
and while the leather may look cool the
experience
wasn't all that great for jolene jolene
is allergic to leather which means that
every time she put on her costume she
would break out into a terrible rash
she said my hands started breaking out
in massive red itchy patches
luckily it wasn't too long before the
makeup department noticed and started
using foam sealant and talc to help her
out
bike ride the batpod rider for catwoman
so when you see the bike scooting around
that's me bobby holland tantan knows all
about chris hemsworth and it's because
he's been his stunt double for years
which means he's run into some
unfortunate costume troubles
see bobby is a few inches shorter than
chris and the only way around that was
for bobby to wear stilts
he said it felt like doing stunts in
high heels and has actually been injured
because of them
imagine doing thor level stunts in high
heels no wonder chris told him to just
stop using them
there is always that element of danger
and you do pick up
injuries along the way you know there
was also the whole situation involving
the fat suit in avengers end game
he said it's not easy dressing up like
thor as it is
let alone when he's piled on some pounds
and we were shooting in atlanta at the
height of summer so
that was difficult it's very demanding
on the body so you need to make sure
that you're prepared the best way you
possibly can be
marvin ross was tom hall in stunt double
during filming for captain america civil
war
and we're sorry to say being a
spider-man wasn't all it was cut out to
be
you have a metal arm that is awesome
dude part of his costume was wearing a
harness and being attached to a string
he would constantly need to shoot scenes
where he was being slammed into the
ground and it was
all out of his control it was so painful
and intense he remembers not even being
able to taste anything when it was all
over
our question is how did he get up and do
it all again the next day
do it
yeah mulan's costume in the new disney
live action
is intense now imagine taking a swim
while wearing it
that's what one of the film's stunt
doubles ashley fito did
she wore the costume including the cape
armor boots
and sword all while shooting underwater
she says
it was basically swimming with an added
30 pounds
filming water scenes for mulan also gave
her a minor concussion
i felt a bit concussed as i was falling
deeper down through the water
once i hit my head i kept on getting
dragged down sounds like an
actual nightmare it's definitely not an
easy job
and it's like be be prepared to do
things
joanna bennett has done it all she's
been a stunt double for characters like
mara wonder woman
and captain marvel while she says 2 am
call times and
hours in a makeup chair are pretty bleak
the worst part about being a stunt woman
is the costumes
having to fight in tight clothes and
high heels isn't the greatest
and a lot of the time uncomfortable but
thanks to actresses like brie larson
joanna is getting the recognition she
deserves for her work
so exciting to be a part of bringing
such a strong female character to life
greg lane was the man of many characters
for lord of the rings filming
but when it came to doubling for a
berserker the experience was dangerous
like a lot of actors he spent 16 hours
in the makeup chair getting prosthetics
put on
but that wasn't the worst part his
costume was too heavy and so was the
torch he had to carry
so heavy that when he had to run with it
he was actually
burning other actors deadpool may be
hilarious but behind the scenes wasn't
always a comedy
michelle smith was the stunt double for
angel dust and says the experience was
so demanding on her body
she was forced to wear a harness that
pulled her in all different directions
listen to her tell us how it sent her to
the chiropractor on her days off
so i did a lot of physio a lot of
massage a lot of cairo so if i had a day
off that's where i was
one look at the beast costume from the
live-action beauty and the beast and you
can probably tell it wouldn't be great
to wear
well stuntman adam basil says it made
his job extremely difficult
he called working in the suit taxing and
demanding because he could hardly move
around in it
we all know how much jim carrey hated
getting his makeup done for the grinch
but we forget his stunt double jonathan
nelson had to go through the same
process
except he also did stunts he says it was
hot and binding and that he had to work
around
how he would move and do his stunts
because of how big it was
in this case he's giving credit to jim
for how long he wore it
if you give them the opportunity they
will be paul darnell didn't have a
problem with the costume when he was
henry cavill's stunt double and man of
steel
but he had to actually transform his own
body
he was forced to gain 25 pounds in a
short amount of time by hitting the gym
at 4 30 am
every single morning is that even
possible
or healthy like sequences and stunt
sequences
they're a lot of fun to do janelle
curfman was karen gillan's stunt woman
on jumanji the next level
and absolutely despised ruby
roundhouse's short shorts
she and karen even bonded over it i went
in for my fitting and i was like karen
i swear these shorts are shorter this
year but they learn to turn the shorts
into a positive by priding themselves on
how hard they work to look good in them
we love girl power angelina jolie really
does it all
including her maleficent stunts but her
intense three-hour long makeup led to a
lot of complications
she was constantly tripping and falling
into things because of her high heels
and when she would do wire work
her horns would get stuck and completely
ruin the take
talk about dedication women can be many
things yeah
imagine risking your life just by
walking into work every day and doing
your job
our level of respect for these
performers is through the roof right now
they rarely receive any credit but it
just goes to show us how much they love
their jobs
what painful costume did you think was
the most shocking